for nba forward he is now nba an nba tv
joins here on the show what was your
reaction to reading about kv
trade you know thanks me on the thought
it was you know just you know one of
those things that came out of nowhere
but you  obviously can see that you know it
was something that was there you look
at
orev because future lebron
james you know lebron
james
next
try do
now
he
tries
to part of this report that stood out to
mean was the explicit reference that was
made that  kyrie said he no longer to
play with
le lock next
season i don't i don't think it makes it
impossible because it depends on you
know what was actually said and let's
just face it i mean obviously every
player that's a robins to  be a batman
they want to be a batman on every team
and i don't know like the facts of this
this we all speculation but look you
know play alongside lebron james listen
wi eas conference finals you're winning
going to the nba finals  consecutive
years and you want to be in a position
where you're the leader you're the
batman and you're the guy that's leading
teams trust me it's not going to be as
easy without a guy like lebron james but
if that's a challenge  that up for
obviously you got a championship under
your belt you're considered one of the
best superstars in this game and you
want to take on that next challenge just
understand the pros and the cons of what
you
jes do you think le james to
with i think he's one the you know one
of the most un superstars i ever seen in
the game of basketball you know with
that being you know one of the best all
basketball players seen in my life you
know from
sc
do
you
his
inri and  you going for he shows sign sl
down that window for being successful
for the cleveland cavaliers still going
to be extremely successful you know and you
know you looking at the eastern
conference you have two contenders out
there washington bon some ton raptors
but after that you cleveland you super
e conference you don't up a you know and
i hate to see this happen the
speculations is true yeah one of the
things i wonder and we're talking toan
butler for nba for joining me here dan
patrick show one of the  things that i
wonder is that if a couple of years from
now kyrie irving regrets doing what he's
trying to do because we've seen in the
past star players for out
of to
st mar what he did in minnesota with
kevin garnet we all know  sh and kobe
what they have said doing things a
little bit
differently if i to make a prediction i
would think that a few years from now
kyrie irving is a phenix son or a member
of the orlando magic that he looks back
all this maybe has some
regrets man a l of specials out
special what
could
hill possi and vince carter and t sh
kobe you know the goes on with these
dynamic duos and pairs and you know
russell westbrook and kd and what could
have happened what would happened but
you know it's all  about you know what's
making you happy look this window
opportunity for you to be on this
platform is only so long and you know i
reference to some of those because you
know our timeline our basketball
history and when you're in the in the
moment  of your career it's always things
that you can you know kind of go back to
the history of the game and resonate
with and that's what you know some of
the guys need to do you know do your
research and see the the cause and
effect of you  know what can happen and
you know for for the majority of those
guys that went through those situations
they had a lot of positive things that
come out of it and a lot of negative you
know you look at sh when he went to miam
still w a championship  but you know
imagine what the dominance could have
been with him and kobe for years
hopefully in and hopefully those guys
can make you know w it's to be inter to
see what happen forward you played for l
of
organ some good some not so good as  a
player how are
you
tur
rel
unknown does seem the st situation
howers what going on above
them i mean back in the past you know it
was it was really more a secret of thing
but now because of social media and
because you know relationships and
contacts you know things are more in the
forefront so there's no more secrets out
there you know you kind of get
information something that you have
access to all information so there fire
and things that you can't cover up once
gets it run and right  now you know
running a full marathon so guys know
what the of the organization is
cleveland you know inside out and the
superstar guys know that you know going
forward you know they got to protect the
legacy they got to protect the brands
and you know guys are  looking at it from
a long
term
it i would think as a young player and
kyrie is only 25 years old seems like
he's been around forever but he's only
25 i would think as a young player that
the general manager and the owner is
just as  important as the head coach
because these are the guys that you're
trusting your future to it's why i think
guys like oklahoma city because sam pry
is there it's why guys like san antonio
because rc buf and greg popov have a
terrific track record of success  i would
think
absolutely and you you want to have
stability and you know the happen of the
gm you know that was that was a huge
blow that was deviously was that lebron
and those guys you know
was
compl then look forward where you know
you  heard rums where lebron wasn't
really happy with the acquisition that
you know they made so far this summer
you know with guys like jamal crawford
out there and free agencies and stuff
like that you know and not adding them
to the team to kind of b  the roster up
because you know the golden state
warriors going to be there they're going
to be there for the next two or three
years and you know it needs to be teams
out there to compete with them and if
you go as a as you  did last year you're
not going to be successful so you're
looking at you know the progress of the
team and once stagnant you know you have
question is this the place for me to be
and i think k is do le as always  great
with stuff the
time thanks bro
but me here on the dan patrick show dan
patrick show
we
a